my name is Chris and I'm gonna mix all
the milk I can find together that's too
far wait there we go that's a little
better nice and close you are so close
to me that you can probably see the
pimple on my forehead or the stains on
my shirt now I say we just get right
into it folks I love milk and there are
a lot of different milks out there there
are many milks every day it seems like a
new milk is emerging from something that
you didn't even think was possible
animals nuts plants so I'm gonna head
out get as many different milks as I can
and mix them into one drink now is this
a bad idea I honestly don't know yet am
I going to feel very sick afterwards
probably but you can't tell me you're
not at least a little bit curious of
what all the milks taste like when
they're together and honestly that's it
let's not overcomplicate things we're
just drinking milk today I don't know
why I put the camera over here let the
milk quest begin
Oh Oh milk John this is what I'll be
pouring a little bit of each milk into I
don't know what's gonna happen but I'm
excited to drink all of these milks
let's get to it
milk milk cows milk got my milk tasting
glass Cheers
God milk is good we are going to start
our mega milk with just a little huh
next Oh
kefir I don't know what it is this
smells like yogurt pour a little into
our glass oh it's thick
bottoms up whoa oh I like this in
between milk and yogurt mmm okay now
we've got buttermilk I don't know anyone
who uses buttermilk like over cereal it
does say milk on it which kind of leaves
me no choice
little taste buttermilk is like a little
sour
it's like tangy goat milk I don't know
what to expect I love goat cheese that's
a big pork that's so weird that tastes
like milk but goat cheesy which makes
sense because it that was too much
soy milk also never had soy milk oh it's
dark ice creamy sweet quality to it
it's going in Oh chocolate milk baby
I'll pour it in here give a little
swirly swirly God day unstoppable here
we go nice tall or can't tell if it's
mixing or like swirling up Oh milk this
is a hot milk I've heard a lot of people
talking about Oh milk to the oats
hmmm it's very similar to almond milk
into the jug it goes what is that rice
milk I love rice I have no idea if rice
milk isn't it taste anything like rice
I'd like to let the record show that I
have not spilled a single drop of milk
on this table and it's gonna stay that
way to rice it's really just throwing me
for a loop because it's just milk milk
milk milk milk milk milk
I almost poured myself a second glass Oh
double glass yeah that's good that gets
a big poor baby I feel like a milk drunk
right now
oh there are so many of these this and
it just says plant milk oh no it is
thick give it oh it's chunky to the
plants and your sweet sweet milk and
smells very interesting that taste is
exactly what you'd think it'd be plant
milk
Oh cashew it smells like cashews go
figure that tastes like cashew water go
cashew go
flax milk is that a seed is that a plant
oh that looks thick and I really want to
emphasize how much I hate the phrase nut
butter but that's what it smells like
this one is very puzzling keep building
excellent coconut milk oh I think I like
that it is very creamy final milk almond
milk keeping it nice and classic so
close to spilling that but it didn't
yeah
let's top her off okay
these are all the milks I didn't feel
sick until I've looked at all of them on
the table at once
got a little stirring spoon you guys
should see this up close there were
little floaty bits in here earlier but a
good
a good stir will take care of that all
right the time has come
[Music]
oh god that looks so sick this here is a
glass of every milk for the everyday
person I wasn't nervous until literally
this second Cheers
what if I just projectile vomited on
camera I got news for you folks that is
perfectly fine it literally tastes like
a combination of all this stuff I think
we should get more people to try this
[Music]
this is the Bob is not great yeah it
just kind of tastes like a lot of milks
we put it on my cereal
Wow there there it is 13 milks all mixed
together it's all the milks I could find
not bad
would drink again thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]